- Tschüss, ihr Lieben!
Der Fisch war sehr lecker.
- Das freut uns.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche beim Fußball.
- Ja, bis dann! Am Freitag um eins.
- Nein, Yanis, wir sehen uns
am Freitag um zwei.
- Max?
- Ja?
- Was muss ein Bankkaufmann machen?
- Ein Bankkaufmann?
Äh …
- Geld zählen?
- Ja, manchmal muss ein Bankkaufmann
auch Geld zählen.
Und ein Bankkaufmann muss Kunden
beraten, er muss Finanzen überprüfen
und Termine mit Kunden organisieren.
- Ah, okay.
- Es ist viel Büroarbeit.
- Büroarbeit?
- Ja, Büroarbeit.
Du musst zum Beispiel …
E-Mails schreiben und
Verträge unterschreiben.
Und natürlich immer schön freundlich sein!
- Das müssen wir im Restaurant auch.
- Ja, aber nicht immer.
- Und ein Elektriker?
- Ein Elektriker muss Geräte installieren
oder er repariert etwas.
- Das klingt cool!
- Das ist es auch.
Aber Max hat recht. Hier sind wir
die Chefs. Das ist besser. Das mag ich.
- Ja. Wir müssen viel arbeiten.
Aber die Arbeit ist super.
- Cool.
- Was ist das denn?
Oh, nein. Das ist Lisas Mappe.
Die braucht sie.
- Ja, na los! Bringt Lisa die Mappe!
- Komm!